I don't know I I feel like people that
that anonymity is what gives people the
troll status on like YouTube comments
and gives people are like somebody came
at me because somebody left a comment on
vampire mom and said why not vampire
dentists wanna vampire this why not
vampire that and I said it sounds like
you have a lot of great story ideas you
should go make a series and then
somebody else left to comment oh you
can't disturb the Emperor's New Clothes
you can't because you know you look a
little bush league and I said critical
dialogue has a function and a form that
guy asked me a bunch of questions and
then all his feedback was why didn't you
make a vampire show about Dennis so
instead of going point my point
answering all the questions I'm
recognizing that his agenda is just a
with me so I'm going to with him
cuz I did stand-up he's a heckler
you so ya know so I'm gonna explain to
him so I so I explained the guy that and
and I said and by the way your face by
the way you're talking i can see that i
can see your agenda you're just trying
to Punk with and and he was and he only
did was comment but point taken and it
was just like wow I've never had a char
all go down like so quit but that was
the things like I understand point so so
putting the twitter by saying you're a
guru saying that you're an expert I
don't know if you would walk around the
name tag with your name on it that said
guru expert out of world
and I just think the thing that makes
social media not shitty is people being
real and we can like I've had people say
you're doing Twitter well you can't talk
punk alike back and every time i get
another thousand followers on vampire
mob I say dear jackass who told me that
I was doing Twitter wrong say hello to
my thirteen thousand followers
every thousand and I got
another thousand today coming up for
14,000 because that's because the show
just keep people keep finding it and
that's the thing about the Internet
that's the thing about Twitter bios it's
like that that's corporate that's
what you do with the factory that's you
know that's that's linkedin you know i'm
not on linkedin you know i'm on twitter
I'm just a person I just tell stories
i'm not so why don't we all like be like
hey how you doing good how are you
pretty good what are you working on
Brighton this thing cool I'm coffee what
are you doing just you know I work at
home I don't have co-workers so
Twitter's kind of like her that's my
water cooler that's my hangout that's my
and I think that's why the relationship
my relationship with the audience is
different because I can't I don't tell
stories all the time because I'm only
one guy so it takes me a while to get
the money and put it together and shoot
it put it out so
so the rest of the time I'm talking
about Mike Mike had posted pictures of
him and post pictures of this place and
I mean that's really
that's that's human that's not that's
not demographics and ratings and all
that
you